chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is looking at how last night's
results could change the Democratic
primary still to come
major good morning to you how does that
line go reports of my death have been
greatly exaggerated because I'm thinking
Joe Biden is waking up feeling really
good tonight how did this morning how
does he keep that momentum going what
does he need to do I have three more
weeks like the week he just had okay
let's just start there and I know we
wanted to leap forward always in
political journalism but we really
should pause just for a second and
remind ourselves what happened in this
Pratt past week Gail you and I were in
South Carolina on that debate stage Joe
Biden said he's gonna win the South
Carolina primary after the debate I
asked him by how much he said one point
will be good enough for me then he gets
the Jim Clyburn endorsement then he wins
the South Carolina primary not by one
point but by 29 percentage points he
raises ten million dollars thereafter
Peabody says drops out Amy Klobuchar
drops out Harry Reid endorses Joe Biden
the former majority leader basically
discounting the very caucus he helped
create where Bernie Sanders clocked Joe
Biden and then last night he gets
Democrats in Massachusetts Minnesota
Texas Virginia Alabama Tennessee and
North Carolina all agree on the same
thing what is it Joe Biden should be the
nominee
that is one sensational week in American
politics and that's what he's got to do
again is that going to be easy no
because now all these forces have
coalesced behind Joe Biden his task pull
them together hold them together and
continue to persuade other Democrats
that he is the one and only person to
lead this more major by my calculations
Mike Bloomberg spent about 30 million
dollars per delegate won last night sure
what does he do now well he assesses as
the campaign said and he could throw in
the towel right now and say you know
what it didn't work my sense is he's
gonna stay around for at least a little
while longer and don't forget this I
know there is this sense of massive
futility behind the Bloomberg effort and
for him personally it did not work out
at least not last night but 95% of the
content and Mike Bloomberg's ad does not
about anyone who's the Democratic field
who's it about Donald Trump what is she
does it raise his ability to lead during
a crisis well we're in one right now
with coronavirus
that money may not have helped Mike
Bloomberg but it does lay a predicate
for an evaluation of President Trump
later on and it might not have been
money ill spent in the long run major
before we let you go Bernie Sanders he's
got a broad in his support if he wants
to be victorious how does he do that
well he has to not only broaden his
support but first you have to create a
message that is more inclusive and
Bernie Sanders talks about what he's
building this multi-generational
multiracial coalition well last night
was a pretty good test of that it didn't
show up yes he had decent numbers among
younger and some minority voters but not
in sufficiently large enough numbers to
do anything but win in California but
winning in California by not nearly the
margin that the Sanders campaign
expected that campaign is not one known
for retooling it's basically the same
message over and over and over again
well last night should have been a
wake-up call all right major thank you
very much